ich werde mich nicht um eine
kanzlerkandidatur bewerben
ein paukenschlag annegret kramp
karrenbauer verzichtet auf ihr vorrecht
und den cdu vorsitz will sie auch bald
abgeben
ein sturm mit folgen orkantief sabine
würdet nicht nur über deutschland
premiere in hollywood erstmals führt die
oscar jury mit parasite einen
ausländischen film auch zum besten film
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
einer neuen woche die eben so
ereignisreich beginnt wie die alte
geendet hat auch der sport hat einiges
zu bieten mit kristin otto kern schönen
guten abend
nachdem thüringen debakel kommt es
schlag auf schlag für die cdu
heute nun die ankündigung von cdu-chefin
kramp karrenbauer sich vom parteivorsitz
im bund zurück zu ziehen
gleichzeitig erklärte sie ihren verzicht
auf die kanzlerkandidatur bis die
geklärt sei will sie aber noch im amt
bleiben
damit droht der cdu nur 14 monate nach
der wahl der parteivorsitzenden ein
neuer machtkampf mathis feldhoff
es ist ein bild der täuschung die
versammelte cdu-führung lächelt in die
kameras doch alle beteiligten wissen
schon dass sie quasi führungslos sind
mit dem verzicht stürzt kramp
karrenbauer ihre partei völlig
überraschend in eine krise diese
entscheidung ist seit einer geraumen
zeit in mir gereift und gewachsen
gescheitert weil sie an der trennung von
kanzlerschaft und parteivorsitz so ak es
hat sich bis in die jüngsten tage
gezeigt dass damit eine ungeklärte
führungsfrage einher geht nämlich die
frage nach der kanzlerkandidatur nicht
nur die eigene truppe auch die
schwesterpartei wurde überrascht ein
offenbar genervt der csu-chef erteilt
seinen rat auf twitter aber es ist jetzt
notwendig die inhaltliche und personelle
aufstellung der cdu grundsätzlich zu
klären
die bombe die die cdu-vorsitzende da
platzen lässt hinterlässt ein vakuum
jetzt sind beide führungsfrauen der cdu
auf abruf kramp karrenbauer und merkel
ich habe diese entscheidung heute mit
allergrößtem respekt zur kenntnis
genommen sage allerdings auch dass ich
sie bedauere es war allerdings merkels
satz von der unverzeihlichen wahl mit
der sie kramp karrenbauers machtverlust
demonstriert hatte eine einmischung die
vor allem im osten nicht gut ankommt
dass der koalitionsausschuss
ein text beschlossen hat ist auch nicht
hilfreich was heißt denn ein
unverzeihlicher vorgang ist das wirklich
die sprache die demokraten miteinander
pflegen sollten
kramp-karrenbauer erfährt heute viel
dank ein nachfolger meldet sich
allerdings nicht sie hat für die einheit
der union gesorgt sie hat das verhältnis
zur csu wieder auf eine gute basis
gebracht und wir bedauern den heutigen
rückzug bis zu einer entscheidung über
einen kandidaten villa k im amt bleiben
das könnte bis dezember dauern
ja warum jetzt warum so schnell theo
koll in berlin hat kam karrenbauer das
vertrauen der kanzlerin verloren
also ich glaube frau kramp karrenbauer
fehlte das vertrauen und die
unterstützung von vielen in der partei
aber dass der kanzlerin hatte sie im
wesentlichen sie war sogar regelmäßig
bei internen besprechungen im kanzleramt
dabei um quasi vorbereitet zu werden auf
das angepeilte regierungsamt und dennoch
trägt gerade die kanzlerin einen teil
der verantwortung im scheitern von
arkadin das lange festhalten an der
kanzlerschaft hat ihrer cdu nachfolgerin
im grunde machtpolitisch quasi den
sauerstoff entzogen
kramp karrenbauer war zwar im parteiamt
aber nicht an der macht auch deswegen
versucht die cdu jetzt den nächsten
parteivorsitzenden so spät wie möglich
aufzustellen damit es ihr oder ihm nicht
genauso ergeht aber natürlich hat auch
annegret kramp karrenbauer selbst einen
gehörigen anteil an ihrem eigenen
scheitern patricia wieder mal hat einige
der stationen des macht verfalls
zusammengefasst es ist gar nicht so
lange her dass angela merkel ihre
wunschkandidatin durchgesetzt hat dass
annegret kramp karrenbauer als siegerin
aus dem kampf um den parteivorsitz
hervorgehen ihr ziel damals aus der
union mit allen flügeln mit allen
mitgliedern mit allen die verantwortung
tragen die gemeinsame die große
volkspartei der mitte zu erhalten und zu
formen
doch genau das schafft sie nicht die
union verliert bei den folgenden
landtagswahlen die parteiflügel driften
auseinander die fehler der vorsitzenden
häufen sich
so macht kramp karrenbauer im karneval
scherze die nicht ankommen
fast hilflos reagiert sie auf das
kritische video des youtube us-riese sie
dort verteidigungsministerin obwohl sie
mehrfach erklärt hatte nicht ins
kabinett zu gehen unabgesprochen ihr
vorstoß für eine schutzzone in syrien
das jahr ist noch nicht rum da muss
kramp karrenbauer beim nächsten
parteitag schon die vertrauensfrage
stellen
die kritik aus den eigenen reihen wird
zunehmend lauter lasst es uns heute
aussprechen und lasst es uns heute auch
beenden hier und jetzt und heute doch
noch stark die partei ihr den rücken
das debakel von erfurt jedoch zeigt
deutlich ihre führungsschwäche
die thüringer cdu hält sich nicht an
ihre vorgaben das eigentliche machtwort
spricht angela merkel aus dem fernseh
afrika sie stellt klar dass dieser
vorgang unverzeihlich ist fehler wenig
klare kante all das hat jetzt zum
rückzug geführt tja und jetzt gibt es da
ein paar herren in der cdu die auf ihre
chance gewartet haben dürften oder ja
ich glaube davon dürfen wir getrost
ausgehen es wird keinen mangel an
bewerbern geben genannt werden natürlich
cdu-intern die vertrauten namen loud
shade märz und sparen und mit jedem von
ihnen verbindet sich aber auch die große
richtungsfrage nrw-ministerpräsident
laschet steht er für den bisherigen
merkel mitte kurs märz oder sparen haben
höhere glaubwürdigkeit nach rechts und
dürften versuchen dort auf die wähler
zurückzugewinnen
wer auch immer es wird er wird ein
schweres partei erbe antreten mit viel
zerrissenheit und für die union
ungewöhnlich relativ wenig loyalität
danke für ihre einschätzung theo wie es
weitergeht mit der cdu das interessiert
natürlich auch die anderen parteien
allen voran den koalitionspartner die
spd heike slansky mit dem reaktion
endlich mal nicht selbst im visier die
spd spitze schaut auf den
koalitionspartner und warnt vor einem
rechtsruck der zustand der cdu sei
besorgniserregend
die cdu befindet sich
in einem richtungsstreit und sie ist
seit längerem erkennbar führungslos
jetzt muss die cdu ihr verhältnis zu
rechtsextremisten klären und sie muss
vor allen dingen auch klären wie es mit
den eigenen kräften in der eigenen
partei bestellt ist etwa der werte union
die ard sieht einen bruch in der union
die cdu zerfällt in zwei lager sowie
erscheint im konservativ bürgerliches
lager und einen links-grün ideologisches
von frau merkel
das debakel in thüringen und die folgen
für grüne und linke ganz klar die cdu
hat sich in eine sackgasse manövriert
die cdu hängt immer noch der hufeisen
theorie an wonach sie linke demokraten
gleich sitzt mit den faschisten der afd
diese hufeisen theorie gehört endgültig
entsorgt wenn die cdu das nicht tut wird
sie auch nicht aus ihrer krise
herauskommen mit dem rückzug von frau
kramp karrenbauer auch als
parteivorsitzende ist die situation wie
gesagt in thüringen nicht gelöst es ist
wichtig dass die demokratischen parteien
dort vor ort miteinander reden
es liegt der vorschlag nach wie vor auf
dem tisch dass der alte
ministerpräsident erneut antritt die fdp
hält sich heute bedeckt zu kramp
karrenbauers rückzug
das ist eine entscheidung die die cdu
bewerten muss und frau kramp karrenbauer
ganz persönlich ich werfe da keine
steine hinterher
die krise in thüringen hat längst berlin
erreicht egal wie oft das mantra keine
zusammenarbeit mit der ard wiederholt
wird direkt nach dieser sendung ein zdf
spezial zum rückzug von kramp
karrenbauer und auf heute de gibt es
mehr zu denen die als nachfolger
gehandelt werden
und wie geht es in thüringen weiter der
frühere ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
hält einen weiteren stillstand für so
wörtlich staatspolitisch
verantwortungslos und strebt seine
baldige wiederwahl an
kommende woche wolle die linkspartei mit
der cdu reden sagte ramelow und klare
vereinbarungen mit teilen der fraktion
treffen
ramelow hofft dass abgeordnete von cdu
oder fdp
eine wiederwahl unterstützen nach dem
wahldebakel von erfurt gibt es immer
mehr anfeindungen gegen politiker vor
allem gegen die der fdp
privathäuser werden beschmiert
geschäftsstellen und plakate beschädigt
und das im ganzen land außerdem klagt
die partei über beleidigungen und
droh-mails auch die afg ist betroffen in
hamburg wurde das wohnhaus ihres
spitzenkandidaten nockemann mit
farbflaschen beworfen
dabei wurden fenster beschädigt und
jetzt zum wintersturm seit gestern hält
sabine weite teile deutschlands in atem
von der küste bis zu den alpen an vielen
orten haben umgestürzte bäume häuser
beschädigt autos zertrümmert und den
verkehr teilweise zum erliegen gebracht
straßen und autobahnen mussten gesperrt
werden hunderte flüge gestrichen und die
bahn stellte den fernverkehr gestern
abend deutschlandweit einluden leinhos
berichtet wenigstens einer hat richtig
spaß an sabine diesem kitesurfer bei
dagebüll kann es gar nicht stürmisch
genug sein wohl eine frage der
perspektive der fährbetrieb nach amrum
und föhr eingestellt landunter auf den
halligen denn mit sabine kommt die
sturmflut in hamburg schwappt die elbe
über die kaimauer der fischmarkt könnte
komplett überflutet werden riesiges
glück in mülheim an der ruhr
fahrer und beifahrer dieses autos
erleiden nur leichte verletzungen als
eine 25 meter hohe eiche hinten auf den
wagen stürzte der baum eine sekunde
früher gefallen hätten sie tot sein
können also so ist das sehr glimpflich
ausgegangen in pforzheim in baden
württemberg wirft eine sturmböe diesen
sattelschlepper um ein auto wird
komplett darunter begraben
der fahrer bleibt unverletzt auf dem
münchner flughafen werden fast 500 flüge
gestrichen die mitarbeiter auf dem
vorfeld dürfen bei diesem wind
geschwindigkeiten keine flugzeuge
beladen
bei der bahn läuft der verkehr in nord
und mitteldeutschland wieder an
im süden und südwesten geht's weiter
beeinträchtigungen den komplettstopp am
sonntag wird die bahn als erfolg die
gefahr bei diesem starken orkan war zu
groß dass bäume die oberleitungen
beschädigen dass sie die strecken
blockieren
wir wollten unbedingt verhindern dass
züge auf freier strecke bei diesen
schwierigen wetterbedingungen liegen
bleiben dass sie auch weitgehend
gelungen und es bleibt stürmisch in
deutschland schon in der nacht dürfte
der wind wieder zunehmen
und da so ein zweiter sturm häufig dann
auf bäume trifft die schon etwas
angeknackst sind können die schäden dann
durchaus größer ausfallen als jetzt bei
dem ersten sturm auch morgen bleibt es
ungemütlich mit graupelschauern es zu
rechnen die schneefallgrenze sinkt auf
200 meter das sturmtief hat auch in
anderen ländern gewütet mindestens vier
menschen kamen dabei ums leben
in polen wurden eine frau und ihre
tochter in der nähe eines skilifts von
herabfallenden dach teilen erschlagen
stromausfälle und überschwemmungen gab
es gleich in mehreren teilen europas wie
hier in wales
auch der flugverkehr war stark
beeinträchtigt diese maschine versuchte
vergeblich in london zu landen
zu stark waren die sturmböen welche
kraft die entfesseln können zeigen diese
aufnahmen aus oberösterreich bäume
werden entwurzelt und fallen um wie
dominosteine keiner der 20 china
rückkehrer ist derzeit im corona virus
erkrankt das haben tests gezeigt gestern
waren 16 erwachsene und vier kinder in
berlin tegel gelandet
sie hatten sich in der am schwersten
betroffenen stadt hochheim aufgehalten
trotz der testergebnisse müssen sie noch
zwei wochen in einer klinik in
quarantäne bleiben
ein perfekter start ohne komplikationen
am frühen morgen ist eine sonde der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa von
cape canaveral aus ins all gestartet
ziel der mission der name solar orbiter
verrät assist die sonne
150 millionen kilometer entfernt das ist
die raumsonde in original
ein hitzeschild aus titan sorgt dafür
dass die temperaturen bis zu 500 grad
celsius aushält schon auf der knapp
zweijährigen reise führt solar orbiter
messungen durch und sammelt daten dann
untersucht der sonnenwinde und das
magnetfeld der sonne geht alles gut
dauert die mission zehn jahre zurück zur
erde
überraschung war ein häufiges wort in
hollywood denn unerwartet erklomm ein
südkoreaner den film olymp bon joon
hohes sozialsatire parasite gewann
gleich vier oscars fast schon erwartet
der oscar für hoher kind phoenix als
bester schauspieler in düsteren thriller
joker und für renée zellwegers
darstellung der judy garland dritter
jäger perry site ist bester film und
schreibt damit oscar geschichte zum
ersten mal gewinnt ein nicht
englischsprachiger film
in der königskategorie wir haben nie
geglaubt dass das jemals passiert wir
sind glücklich die koreanische
sozialsatire erzählt die geschichte
einer armen familie die sich wie ein
parasit bei einem neureichen plan
einrichtet
wirklich sehr viele kunst wäre bei uns
ausprobiert
bester hauptdarsteller wird vor kind
phoenix für seine rolle in the joker
mein ganzes leben
alle nicht klar ob ich überhaupt
existiert
frauen und nicht weiter hatten auch in
diesem jahr weniger chancen auf trophäen
heftig debattierte hollywood darüber im
vorfeld renée zellweger wird beste
schauspielerin für ihre rolle im drama
judy ihrem schauspiel ikone juliane
bekommt den oscar für den besten
nebendarsteller in once upon a time in
hollywood und kommentiert das
amtsenthebungsverfahren des us
präsidenten das ohne zeugen endete sie
haben mir gesagt ich habe nur 45
sekunden immerhin 45 sekunden mehr als
der senat john bruton gegeben hat mit
einem aber ist hollywood wohl
einverstanden dass eine südkoreanische
film group mit insgesamt vier oscars der
abräumer des abends ist und jetzt zum
sport und einer klaren absage ihres t
liegt ziemlich konsequent nach dem
gestrigen torlosen unentschieden der
bayern gegen leipzig in der bundesliga
distanziert sich fußball stürmerstar
thomas müller eindeutig von der
nationalmannschaft eine rückkehr sei
kein thema die em abgehakt er hätte
andere ziele
wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein soll es wird
zwar viel hineininterpretiert aber diese
europameisterschaft die interessiert
mich aktuell überhaupt nicht sondern
mich interessiert dass wir hier können
wir schneller zeigen
das soll dieses jahr titel holen und
zwar eins geht drei stück berauschende
aufholjagd in der italienischen liga
inter mailand entscheidet nach dem 0
2-rückstand das brisante stadtderby
gegen den ac mailand mit 4 2 für sich
derby gewonnen tabellenspitze erobert
trainer konnten inter in italien obenauf
dabei der ac mailand besser in der
ersten halbzeit vorarbeit ibrahimovic
der ex-frankfurter rede trifft milan
führt und erhöht ibrahimovic 0 2 zur
halbzeit aber inter kommt eindrucksvoll
zurück bronze witsch anschlusstor in der
51 resino mit dem ausgleich zwei minuten
später die frau schließlich 20 minuten
vor dem ende 32 spielen
lukaku noch mit dem vierten treffer
hinter verdrängt juventus von der
tabellenspitze
der vorsprung auf ibrahimovic ac beträgt
jetzt 22 punkte und tolle anerkennung
für deutschlands radprofi john degenkolb
fünf jahre nach seinem sieg beim
frühjahrs klassiker paris rom oder einer
der bekanntesten streckenabschnitte nach
ihm benannt und eingeweiht
es ist eine der berühmtesten
kopfsteinpflaster passagen der welt der
papst sektor dorna bandini am arsch
beziehungsweise seit heute der john
degenkolb sektor zu schön um irgendwie
davon irgendwie träumen zu können
deswegen war das war das eigentlich
außer der reichweite 2015 hatte er als
zweiter deutscher paris gewonnen
maßgeblich für die ehrung aber gegen
kurzeinsatz abseits der strecke im
letzten jahr hatte er mit einer
crowdfunding kampagne das
nachwuchsrennen des klassikers vor dem
aus bewahrt
schöne geste und wir haben noch das
wetter das bleibt weiter unruhig sturm
regen und schnee mehr dazu gleich von
gunter czisch so viel von uns wir
empfehlen das heute journal um 21.45 da
sprich claus kleber mit markus söder und
jetzt gleich im anschluss das spezial
zur cdu
danke für ihr interesse und tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
gute pflege zuschauer das stürmische
wetter geht weiter und zwar gleich heute
nach der neue sturm zieht auf ein
kleines tief sehr schnell zieht es über
deutschland mit viel regen in der
zweiten nachthälfte auch mit schnee in
den mittelgebirgen
es wird ja kühler und morgen beruhigt
sich der sturm nur im süden mit diesem
hoch über frankreich heute nacht also
viel regen im süden aber auch im norden
in den mittelgebirgen wird immer mehr
schnee geben bis zum teil auf 300 meter
runter und der sturm lässt nicht nach
ist kann straßenglätte geben bei null
bis sechs grad morgen weitere schauer
schnee regen graupel am nordrand der
mittelgebirge kann es längere zeit
schneien
freundlicher ist es vom münsterland bis
nach sachsen und der sturm liegt nur er
wird nur im süden hier etwas schwächer
sonst bleibt es bei sturm oder schweren
sturmböen im norden die temperaturen
sind etwas niedriger das heißt noch vier
bis neun grad 2 grad in den
mittelgebirgen und es geht wechselhaft
weiter am mittwoch dann beruhigt sich
das wetter erst einmal donnerstag im
westen beträgen am freitag im südosten
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut